art is big business in Britain globally
the market here is second only to the
United States but some fear its future
is a less pretty picture this summer two
of London's major art fairs have been
canceled each of them cited the same
thing brexit
art is a is a global business it's also
very obviously a physical asset that
means often very expensive Works have to
be carefully packed and shipped around
the world clearly any friction in that
process is going to cause problems and
brexit as we know means friction
Gander and white is one of the world's
leading Fine Arts shipping firms their
experience is typical
works of Arts from EU to the UK now
require customs clearancies and payment
of input vat world of art from the UK to
the EU require payment of vat in the
destination country there's increased uh
Customs complex Customs procedures that
we now have to comply with businesses
definitely been affected at 360 380 400
put simply that means fewer sales and
fewer people willing to do business here
organizers of the Masterpiece aren't
Fair one of those that was canceled told
Sky News the number of eu-based
galleries wanting to attend had dropped
by 86 since 2018
it but not everyone is quite so
pessimistic we can't forget over the
last three years we've also had the
global pandemic and obviously more
recently the war in Ukraine and all of
these things have actually had Financial
impacts on the European market and also
the UK Art Market so it's important to
kind of consider it all as a whole and
we can't
pigeonhole it into being directly
related to brexit
some argue that one way to take
advantage of brexit and bolster the
Market's flagging fortunes would be to
scrap import VAT on Art altogether but
in the current climate tax cuts for
millionaire art collectors is an
unlikely political slogan
Sue Thompson Sky News